movies they're everywhere with multiple
new releases coming out every single day
there's just no way anybody has the time
or money to see all of them which is too
bad because it means that a lot of
really good films go completely under
the radar and you may not have even
heard of some of the best films of the
year don't worry though because we've
got your back here's a look at some of
the brilliant movies of 2017 you totally
missed Revenge ask anyone who's ever
been pregnant and they'll tell you that
the whole creating another human with
your own body thing isn't easy
back pain swollen feet and a
rollercoaster of emotions are enough to
make even the most calm people go a
little crazy but in prevent that
pregnancy induced madness quickly turns
to murder writer director Alice Lowe
plays Ruth a pregnant woman grappling
with the death of her partner also due
date nears Ruth begins listening to the
menacing supernatural thoughts of her
unborn child and starts to believe the
world should be held accountable for
ultimately leaving her baby without a
father cue a revenge fueled killing
spree that leads Ruth to reevaluate each
piece of a wildly fragmented life so
that you know you have absolutely no
control of your mind or your body
anymore
this one does oh and that's the
prosthetic belly there though was
actually in her third trimester when she
films prevent talk about method acting
Chuck once upon a time there was a
regular guy named Chuck Wepner installed
liquor and did some price fighting on
the side for cash to support his family
then one day in 1975 he was cherry
picked from a sea of boxes that go
gloves to glove with one of the world's
greatest athletes boxing legend Muhammad
Ali as most film fans know where this
amazing story famously inspired the
classic film rocky I'm going to help you
mister weapon follow boxing rocky good
telling sly I can handle it but unlike
the fictionalized Rocky Chuck aims to
tell the true tale of this unlikely
sports hero with Liev Schreiber in the
lead and a great cast including Naomi
Watts backing him up the lost city of Z
Charlie Hunnam
Robert Pattinson Sienna Miller and the
new spider-man himself Tom Holland T
dubbed for the lost city of z a
thought-provoking adventure tale about a
group of explorers asserting the Amazon
for a legendary lost civilization I call
it death the ultimate piece of the human
puzzle
unfortunately the lost city of Z open
the same weekend of the fate of the
Furious so pretty much nobody had any
idea it existed and there vanished from
the box office almost instantly the good
news that gives you the opportunity to
an earth a cinematic lost treasure of
your own the Transfiguration this one is
definitely not your average vampire
thriller the Transfiguration shifts its
focus away from classic vampire tales to
the story of a young teen named Milo who
shields himself from the unfriendly
outside world with a deep-rooted
fascination with the undead but that
interest turns lethally obsessive when
he becomes friends with the trouble
Sophie leading to a chilling slice of
afterlife indie horror flicks that will
leave you completely transfixed you
change a lot that's the first person you
kill and you change a lot more after
after one after another the devil's
candy ethan embry stars and is simply
delicious horror film about the tortured
artist through black soap and waits to
discover he has painted a horrifying
portrait of pure evil has he been
touched by some kind of holy or unholy
force or is he simply going mad the only
way to find out is to watch The Devil's
candy for yourself if you dare t2 is
Trainspotting to anyone who said sequels
rarely stack up we counter with t2
Trainspotting the 21 years later follow
up to Danny Boyle's classics
Trainspotting two decades on t to peak
cinema life of the gang from the
original with Begbie Renton spurred and
Sick Boy each in an unexpected or or to
expected place in their lives can people
really change or is that just an
illusion we sell ourselves twelve
inventive sequel asks the question but
you may not like the answers let it all
go wrong
where did it all go wrong where did it
all wrong I don't feel at home in this
world anymore
this Netflix exclusive release stars
Elijah Wood and melanie lynskey as a
pair of eccentric neighbors who embark
on a quest to track down the thieves who
burgled her home
their mission quickly melt into chaos
and violence of a frantic Lea try to
outwit a pack of corrupt criminals
following their every move
I don't feel at home in this world
anymore burst forward with an inventive
subversive slyly smart and a downright
fun feel that will have you hollering in
one scene and pondering society's
structure in the next all right your
chance dig two graves the brainchild of
screenwriters Hunter Adams and Jeremy
Phillips the indie horror outing dig two
graves the centers around
fourteen-year-old Jacqueline Martha
referred to by her more masculine
nickname Jake grieving for her recently
deceased brother Jake is thrown for a
loop when she's visited by three strange
men who say they can bring him back to
life I'm not just have to change your
sister my now that we know each other
are they telling the truth what lens
would Jake have to go to see her brother
again and what does a grandfather
Sheriff Waterhouse have to do with it as
Jake begins to contemplate an
unthinkable trade-off dark secrets of
her family's once hidden history rises
to the surface
inspired by gothic motifs of grief and
revenge and the source of the
uncertainty of an ambiguous timeline dig
two graves to the captivate discerning
drama enthusiasts and to though it
didn't make any big wave of the Fox
office given its tiny release dig two
graves have been showered with acclaim
from critics with Roger Ebert calm
calling it an uncommon Lee smart
well-made and ultimately touching
meditation on grief colossal you'd
expect a film with a title like colossal
to be an overhyped summit tentpole but
this pitch-black sci-fi indie comedy
came and went without getting a media
attention it deserved colossal stars
oscar-winning actress Anne Hathaway as
Gloria a woman in the throes of a poster
breakup existential limbo who shocked
realize he actually has bigger problems
than just curving her drinking and
getting back on the dating scene like
giant reptilian kaiju sized problems in
the form of an enormous monster
terrorizing South Korea these two things
don't sound like they could possibly be
part of the same movie but the way
colossal connects them it's just part of
the film's genius Joe my dancing Sarah
you get to film this prom huh you make
any requests this is that last dollar a
distinctly unique take on the monster
movie genre boasting ultra fresh
performances from Hathaway as jason
sudeikis colossal has decidedly strange
in the very best way from the sole
street fight reminiscent of Rock'em
Sock'em robots to the ultimate narrative
twist here's a film weird and wild
enough to stretch your definition of
what a Creature Features should be war
this foreign horror flick is just as
formidable in English as it is in French
war which was called grave in its
original European release starts off so
simply it may even elicit laughter a
movie all about a vegetarian adjusting
to college life amongst meat-eating
peers not exactly captivating but writer
director Julia Duke or now practically
slaps you across the face with a rock of
war
ribs in the moment that follow
happy-go-lucky freshmen and lifelong
plant-eater Justine has high hopes of
veterinary school and intends to be
laser focus on her studies however her
mind soon shifts to a different
unexpected target human flesh the tasty
acquires after she's forced to eat warm
meat during a hazing ritual as Justine
tries to make sense of her newfound
cannibalistic desires
Ross swerves down the winning road of
navigating college parties uppity
professors and the complexities of
sexual identity we won't spoil the
ending but we have a feeling that Ross
third act is what catapulted it into the
lives of many adoring critics and made a
few viewers fall out of their seats
bloody and brutal were oh so bright war
is a film you can really think to keep
them to literally land of mine after
making a big wave the Toronto
International Film Festival and in
Danish theaters in 2015 land of mine
finally hit theaters in America at the
beginning of 2017 not that anyone seems
to notice
that's a shame considering how gripping
land of mine is based on a true story
the film is set in Denmark at the end of
1945 freed from German occupation the
country was still filled with thousands
of hidden land mines sergeant Cole
Rasmussen and his band of German
prisoners of war are tasked with
clearing the explosives a job that
brings into question justice for
alloting and vengeance in a single
breath start intention or technique
leaving Princeton for 6,000 mean yeah
the challenge of this historical drama
earned itself a 20-17 Oscar nomination
for Best Foreign Language Film a
standing ovation at TIFF and the title
of best Danish film of 2015 it's land of
mine is missing from your watch list
change that immediately if not sooner
the salesman a twisty and intriguing
drama from Iran the salesman tells a
story of ahmad and rana a theatre loving
couple who set out to stage a production
of Arthur Miller's classic play of Death
of a Salesman
after Rana is attacked however their
lives are upended as the need for
revenge begins to take center stage in
their lives as a man who shall often
what
emotional abuse Java Harmon one protocol
mellow was Hamish Gavin all of them
Spanish really has one for those days I
might've shortly followed back on an
image lauded as an ingenious cinematic
use of the American stage the salesman's
story within a story brings to light
questions about violence against women
marriage post-traumatic stress death and
the class system has asked the audience
to work through them as the film runs on
it though the salesman might have
slipped past you
it certainly wasn't lost with critics
landing itself the Oscar for Best
Foreign Language Film at the 89th
Academy Awards thanks for watching click
the looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel
Plus check out all this cool stuff we
know you'll love thing
[Music]